bien alors comme je suis très très fan
de vous je vais vous inviter à danser
ses pairs
[Musique]
as peur tu manges pas sur les pieds là
non pas du tout me sens fier me marche
toujours sur les pieds du coup j'ai
l'habitude aux riches est habitué mais
là non c'est bien c'est quoi votre
prénom
vous n'avez pas d'office web
mais bien sûr c'est thierry ardisson ça
c'est en tous cas tout tout tout tout
tout est à moi oui vous savez quoi les
chefs j'adore cette émission ici tuerie
ça vous a plu des fleurs délicates r
c'est que vous aviez une émission il
s'appellerait la classe si vous en avez
de là à vous êtes gémeaux ascendant
poisson ou alors vous savez pas mon
prénom et vous savez mon signé mon
assemblée puisque je me sens ça oui
comment s'est passée sa peau parfait
alliage très embêté parce que je ne
trouve plus il ay s'arrête aux indignés
annexe i way neutre
kevin ouais vous étiez où nous fêtons
cherchez la femme de ma vie mais j'étais
l'affairé si on partait tous les bulles
ou achètent un appartement de 100 foot
c'était fou
on va où volontiers j'adore votre femme
sur cinq jeunes
il vaudrait mieux pousser non plus parce
que c'est
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu